HBO has just put out a second Game of
Thrones Season 6 trailer and some short
clips from the first few episodes
there's some crazy new stuff here so
let's have a quick look again the
trailer starts at the wall with the body
of Jon Snow Davos and ghost and some
loyal night's Watchmen's seem to be
defending Jon's body from The Watchmen
who killed him
including Alliser thorne bo and marsh
and everyone's favorite black brother
Ali Melisandre is around as well so
again this will probably eventually
somehow lead to the resurrection of Jon
whether this will involve sacrifice or
fire or blood or ghosts or White Walkers
we don't yet know we also see more of
bastard bowl the big battle fought
between the Bolton's and the wildlings
in the north just outside Winterfell you
can see the heraldry of houses horn wood
and Mormont and the umbers with the
Bolton's and Davos is here beneath a
stark banner we also see tormund and
Ramsay and the Big Friendly Giant women
bursting through what looks to be the
gates of Winterfell and also that horse
leading the cavalry charge might be
Jon's there's a clip of Theon and Sansa
running through the snow to escape the
Bolton's and we let us see Sansa at the
battlefield wearing stark clothes she
talks about the people who took from her
over shots of Ramsay and what looks to
be a free wedding with Lord Walder and
Lannister soldiers this could be where
Sansa and the Starks take revenge a red
wedding 2.0 ware phrase and Lannisters
slaughtered to avenge Robb and cat and
Ned this can involve the blackfish the
Brotherhood without banners maybe higher
if she crosses the Narrow Sea we don't
really know how it'll go down but one
way or another the phrase will finally
get what's coming to him in Braavos is
still in the house of black and white
with the faceless man still blind though
she seems to get a sight back at some
point he or she is sparring getting
slapped up by the waif and then she's
told that she's on her second and last
chance by Jack and higer or rather by
someone who's wearing Jack ins face
remember last season someone with
Jatin's face took poison and died so
remember that any faceless man can wear
any face they don't really have personal
identities they are no
which is what they're trying to make
ayah but it doesn't look like ire is
willing to let go of who she is the
further east in Mereen Tyrion Varys miss
and I and grey worm try to hold things
together it looks like they're
challenged by the great masters the
original rulers of murine and the sons
of the harpy are still a threat and we
meet a new player apparently called kin
Farah a red priestess like Melisandre
she's looking pretty pleased with
herself here so it'll be really cool to
see what this new red woman brings to
the table we also see Tyrion talking
about dragons not like in captivity and
then he sees regal and Viserion for
himself in the great pyramid basement so
we can probably expect the Dragons to
finally be let loose sometime soon we
see Daenerys in Vaes Dothrak the sacred
city of the Dothraki
she's stripped and downtrodden has her
power and prestige taken away from her
these women are probably the - Colleen
the ex-wives of carl's who in Dothraki
culture are expected to live in Vaes
Dothrak
Jorah is coming to try and save her and
he's bringing his deadly greyscale with
him but Danny salvation will probably be
dragged on so Danny can answer the
disrespect of the Dothraki with fire and
blood on the iron islands we get a bit
of a Greyjoy family reunion Theon meets
with Asha or Yara and uncle Euron turns
up to kill his brother Balin and is
starting to look like a shire is taking
on the role of Victarion from the books
meaning after the Kings mood she may be
sailing east to marine to meet Daenerys
but the evidence is that this girl Asher
is making out with looks like a slave
from volantis and the only reason Asher
would be in volantis would be as a pit
stop to marine so maybe Asher will meet
the dragon Queen in King's Landing
Cersei Lannister is mad as hell Jaime
has brought back the body of Marcella
leaving Tommen her only surviving child
and the sparrows still have Margaery and
Loras Tyrell so she sends Jaime up
against the high Sparrow and [ __ ] gets
real quick a Tyrell army approaches the
great Sept and Lord mace wears a funny
hat Robert strong is let loose on the
sparrows and there is blood at some
point it looks like Jamie goes to the
river lands which
something that happened in the books
Brienne and Podrick also seemed to be
the errant pod is jumped by bran with
Jaime Brienne and pod all in the
Riverlands it might be that they take
part in the stark vengeance of the Frey
wedding somehow and they might also get
involved with Lady Stoneheart if she
turns up bran Stark is beyond the wall
with bloodraven aka Brynden rivers aka
the three-eyed crow who is giving brand
visions of the past including this one
of the fight of the tower of joy between
three of Aerys Targaryen Kings guard and
seven of Ned Stark's men this guy here
may well be the legendary Arthur Dayne
while this bloke who gets shish kebabbed
must be one of Ned's guys but again the
really cool thing about this scene is
that we may get to see Ned sister Lyanna
and the true parentage of Jon Snow we
also see Meera Reed who apparently is
still hanging around in blood Ravens
cave with Hodor and Jojen assuming he
hasn't been eaten by bran and finally we
see the White Walkers striding through
fire riding four horses with Davos
describing the war to come at this point
the walkers have really got two places
left to strike blood Ravens cave and the
wall itself so that's the second trailer
conflict a Castle black huge battle in
the north and maybe vengeance for the
Starks tension rising in the house of
black and white new players in Mereen
Danny against the dosh Killeen Greyjoy
is converging on Pyke with Azure sailing
East [ __ ] hitting the fan in King's
Landing with sparrows and Tyrells and
Bobby strong fighting and also stuff in
the Riverlands bran on the weirwood net
Tower of joy Meera Jojen Hodor and the
others the White Walkers on the attack
this season's going to be crazy so if
you'd like to know more check out our
videos on iodine in greyscale Iran
Robert strong jochen's fate Jon's
resurrection and much much more please
like and subscribe and see you next time
this video was made with the support of
patrons on patreon including Ashley
Whitlock Kacey Coons Kingslayer Jamie
Edmond Dantes Steiner V Simon
Christopher Frogg neshama Abdullah Asuna
Murakami rougarou Philippe tan Chang
Neel Renkin Jacob Knudsen Yaya Paul Nils
caustic mug chip Erik Joey tea team
Garcia and Elle
it book thanks guys
you